Alright we're back. So let's, let's, let's think
this through, so the teacher gets to suggests to
the student any, any question. The teacher knows
the answer, and the teacher would like the learner
to get the answer as quickly as possible.
Not requiring the full 20 questions if, if possible.
So what do you think, what do you think
the teacher could do as a good strategy here?
>> For 20 questions?
>> Yeah.
>> So, if, if we think of the set of
possible people as being these sort of hypotheses. And you know
which of the hypothesis is correct and which is wrong, then presuming the
teacher can keep all this in her head, I guess the right thing to do would be to
always pick an X, such that it gets rid of as many of the hypotheses is
possible. But what, what, do I mean by
that? I mean, it gives the most information.
>> Well, but there's a, there's a very strong kind of information that you
could get in this particular case. So, so, so let's imagine that this set
of questions is, is this sort of, you can ask any question in the universe.
>> So, I give you some question, I oof.
>> Let's, let's try this because remember
we did this before, you thought of a
person, and you had me ask questions. So I want you to think of a person.
>> Okay.
>> Alright, and I want you to tell me what question I should
ask, that's going to figure out who the person is as quickly as possible.
>> Okay. Is this person as
good in his field as his namesake is in his field?
>> Is it Michael Jordan?
>> Yes.
>> Is it the Michael Jordan who's a professor at Berkley?
>> Okay.
>> You could have asked if I say, is it Michael I Jordan?
>> Yeah, I don't think I knew the initials of the two Michael Jordans.
>> Yeah. Michael Jordan, for, for people who
don't know is a professor at Berkley and
one of the giants in machine learning. And
he is literally the Michael Jordan of machinery.
>> [LAUGH]
Alright, but, but, but you could've done this in one question, right?
If you had to ask me, if the first question was, is the
person, and then the actual person. You knew that the answer to
that would be yes. And so I would've gotten it in one step.
>> Hmm, that's true.
>> So, given a, you know a, a sufficiently,
helpful teacher. You can, you can do this in one.
>> Well, that make sense, right? So
basically, if my questions include, is this
the correct hypothesis, then you should always just ask that question.
>> Right.
>> But that seems, that seems like cheating.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, I would, I. You're right and all I was really trying to do
is show that, it's a very different problem,
when the, the question has to come from
the learner's side. That kind of question from
the learner's side would be pure folly. Because
it would, it, it, the learner would not
know what person to pick. If the person started,
if the learner started to ask questions like, is the
person Michael I Jordan? The answer's very likely to be no.
In which case that's not very helpful. Now, a really helpful
teacher could potentially change the
target. But that's, that's definitely cheating.
>> Mmm. OK, fair enough.